i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
my name is zoe roth but you may know me
as disaster girl
this all started in 2005. i was five
years old
and we were watching tv it was a normal
day me my brother tristan and my parents
and we heard all these fire sirens we go
we walk outside and we see like
billowing smoke
up just two blocks away so like okay
we're gonna go check it out
my dad had just gotten a new camera we
start walking down the road
and we see that there's this house on
fire at the time
we thought it was a real fire but all
the fire marshals weren't really in a
rush to put it out they were kind of
just like walking around they're letting
like kids put out the fire the house
that was on fire was donated to the fire
department by the owners for a test burn
because they wanted to clear the land
like i didn't know it was a test fire
that nobody was hurt so at the time i
remember like looking inside and trying
to figure out what was going on
my brother he was really into harry
potter at the time
so he was dressed up as harry potter my
dad was taking pictures of the house and
everything going on and then he said it
was my turn to smile he was like okay
smile
so that's why i made that face just
because that was my smile at the time
any picture from that period i feel like
you could look at it and be like oh like
this definitely looks like the same girl
because
i just had an evil smile fast forward to
2008 we got a magazine in the mail
and my dad said oh zoey you only feed
this magazine i was like okay whatever
and i flip through and like halfway
through it's my picture in there and
that's the first time i had seen it
like i never even saw it after he took
it so it turns out there's this magazine
called jpeg that had this photo
competition called emotion capture
and my dad submitted the picture to it
and it won so i was in second grade at
the time i don't really know much about
jpeg magazine just so my dad liked it a
lot
so i thought that everybody liked it so
obviously i brought the magazine into my
class i showed everybody i showed
everybody in the halls all my teachers
because i was like this is me i'm famous
and to this day that's definitely the
most famous i've ever felt
like nothing has ever compared to me
being in second grade taking my magazine
to class
so a trend started to emerge online
where people started to photoshop
my picture onto different disasters so
they would take my picture in the corner
and they would put something like
horrible behind it like they put
hitler or they put the hindenburg
blowing up
the dinosaurs going extinct the atomic
bomb
britney spears doing her disaster
performance
so that was the first wave of the meme
and then people just started putting
like text
over top of it i never had any fear of
anybody conflating me
with being evil or causing these
disasters
none of my classmates and no one that i
know or i'm close with have ever thought
that but i feel like random people
always think that i'm evil or that i did
start the fire but i never take it too
seriously or get worried about it
obviously the hitler one the alt-right
photoshops make me pretty uncomfortable
and i've never condoned that or enjoy it
but i also know i can't really do
anything about it so i don't let it
get to me being a meme hasn't had a huge
impact on my life like it has for other
people but there's definitely
things here and there that are super fun
there's just been a few times where i'm
just living my normal life and i'm
suddenly asked to be a celebrity for an
hour i'll be working at a restaurant and
then i'm asked to be flown out to do a
documentary and then i'm back at the
restaurant the next day
so i feel like most of my instagram
following is from
indonesia poland and brazil hello if
you're watching this
most of my comments that i get on my
instagram are people from these
countries and my dms i really don't know
why these three countries
are so interested like what the deal is
but
i think it's fun i think it's cool and i
know that there's a portrait of me in
portugal somewhere so if i'm ever in
portugal
or if anybody knows where it is i would
love to go there are we done recording
uh yeah we're done so so did you start
fire
yes
i'm just kidding just kidding
you